vidéo est ce que tu es favorables à
l'avortement
moi je me suis fait avorter plein de
fois j'ai eu un enfant je sais pas si je
me ferait avorter encore avec la même
facilité disons mais je trouve que c'est
un droit inaltérable la peine de mort
je suis contre je suis contre à 400
mille pour cent quand une société aura
prouvé qu'elle a le bien fondé de juger
on reparlera des choses d'ailleurs ce
jour là il y aura plus besoin de peine
de mort est-ce que rapide des lignes si
grave pour ça que tu es pour la
légalisation des drogues douces
oui je suis pour la légalisation et
l'information de tout ce qui vous fait
du bien
quels sont tes tabou chez pas tabou je
dis une fois que tes héros préférés
étaient jésus-christ et pénélope est ce
que pour jésus-christ tu peux nous
expliquer mais c'est très c'est très
évident à comprendre c'était un vrai
révolutionnaire jésus-christ jeudi en
fait le vrai martyr c'est judas parce
que jésus la halle boral et judas lui il
est finalement jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours
il a le mauvais rôle c'est lui le vrai
martyr mais oui on peut très bien voir
ça comme ça ce qui prouve encore qu'il
n'y a pas d'ombré s'il n'y a pas de
lumière et qu'il n'y a pas de vie sans
la mort bien entendu que judas était
quand même la pierre d'achoppement de la
possibilité de sacrifice du christ qui
donc en étant martyrs reste un symbole
pour des générations et des générations
et des millénaires bien entendu que
judas est quelqu'un qui est un symbole
tout aussi puissant et que l'inde vers
rêver d'autres retour d'un voyage aux
indes tu avais découvert le bouddhisme
et tu disais que le bouddhisme répondait
à toutes les questions qu'on se pose est
ce que tu crois toujours ça aujourd'hui
oui ça permet de répondre à toutes les
questions
maintenant encore faut-il pouvoir les
mettre en acte parce que ce qu'on pense
est une chose se compensent donc une
valeur sûre n'arrive pas l'appliquer à
sa vie mais il le dit d'ailleurs ça il
dit nous croire bien que tu une
expérience si tu avais un seul mot à
dire à sa fille un seul message un seul
conseil à lui donner ce serait quoi soit
toi existe résiste et en vie parce que
tant que tu as envie tu es en vie et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux